اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
المستمره من العربيه لتطورات الاوضاع في
السودان لمن انضم الينا الان لا تزال
الاشتباكات مستمره في ولايه مختلفه في
السودان بين قوات الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع بعد ان وصلت المحادثات الى طريق
مسدود بين طرفين بعد هدنه بسيطه في وقت
الافطار وقد شهدت العاصمه الخرطوم انقطاعا
في التيار الكهربائي وتجددت الاشتباكات
سريعا مع اعلان كل طرف تحقيق تقدمات على
الارض مجلس سياده السوداني اكد ان معظم
المنشاه العسكريه والحيويه تحت سيطره
الجيش كما اكدت رئاسه اركان الجيش
السوداني انه لا حوار او تفاهمات قبل
انهاء تفلتات الدعم السريع واكدت مصادر في
الجيش ان مجهودات الرباعيه الدوليه مقدره
لكن ما يحدث هو تمرد يجب ان يتم اخماده
فيما اكد قائد قوات الدعم السريع للع انه
لا يزال يدير العمليات من الخرطوم وايضا
وسط كل هذا تدعو معظم دول العالم رعاياها
الى الالتزام باماكنها وعدم الخروج في
المناطق المفتوحه خصوصا بعد ان علقت معظم
شركات الطيران العالميه او علقت رحلاتها
الى الخرطوم بشكل مؤقت حتى تتكشف نتائج ما
يحدث اليوم
على مطار الجنان الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
يا شباب منورين ده مطار الجنينه يا جماعه
ده مطار الجنينه احتلينا احتلال كامل
وعدد كبير من القتلى والمصابين من
المدنيين سقطوا في الاشتباكات الجاريه
اليوم وفق لجنه اطباء السودان المركزيه
اللجنه ناشدت اطراف النزاع بوقف
الاشتباكات في الخرطوم والمدن السودانيه
عده وفتح مسار للمصابين لتلقي الخدمات
الصحيه وكانت العربيه وثقت اصابات لمدنيين
بعد ان علقوا وسط النيران بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في منطقه بحريه في الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
المفروض
ومن جانبه قال رئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقالي في السودان الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان في تصريحات للعربيه ان المتمردين
من قوه دعم السريع سعو للسيطره على مقرات
الجيش والمناطق الحيويه فجرا اضاف البرهان
متمردون دعم السريع خطته لتنفيذ اغتيالات
وخيار الجيش الوحيد هو التصدي لمطامع من
وصفهم بالمتمردين في السلطه وقال عبد
الفتاح البرهان ان الجيش يدير عمليه ضد
المتمردين بصبر لمنع وقوع اي خسائر بشريه
واكد ان الجيش السوداني لديه القدره
الكافيه واراده لدحر هؤلاء الاشخاص
ومن جانبه ناشد عضو مجلس السياده
الانتقالي في السودان مالك عقار الجيش
وقوات دعم السريع بوقف المعارك الدائره
بينهما على الفور والاحتكام الى صوت العقل
واضاف عقار ان اللجنه الوساطه ستواصل
السعي من اجل تحقيق وقف فوريا لاطلاق
النار ومن ثم معالجه المشكلات التي ادت
لوقوعه مؤكدا انما يحدث امر كارثي وكان
يجب تجنبه او يمكن تجنبه لو التزمت كافه
الاطراف بالروح الوطنيه على حد تعبيره
معنى لا مشاهدينا من الخرطوم مراسل
العربيه سالم الهاشمي اهلا بك يا سالم
معنا سالم كيف تبدو الصوره لديك عاده يعني
الانباء والصور التي وردتنا قبل قليل تفيد
بتجدد الاشتباكات في مناطق مختلفه من
السودان نسيمه في الخرطوم
سالم
نعم ايوه اسمعك اسمعيني نعم سوف لنا الوضع
الان في الخرطوم ومناطق المناطق السودانيه
الاخرى التي شهدت اشتباكات
نعم تجددت الاشتباكات بعد الافطار في ام
درمان هي الاكشخ الان في المنطقه
المحيطه بسلاح المهندسين كنا قد عرضنا
خبرا بسيطره قوات الدعم السريعه على سلاح
المهندسين وقد اصدر الجيش او اخبرنا الجيش
للعربيه والحدث بان سلاح المهندسين تحت
سيطره الجيش وليس هناك اي سيطره داخل سلاح
المهندسين هذا فقط
للتاكيدات بالنسبه للاوضاع هنا في بحري
عاده الاوضاع نسبيا الى الهدوء من بعد
الافطار لم يسمع الدولي الذي كان موجود
ولا اتجدد سماع للطلقات او القذائف او
القنابل حتى كلها الان بدات في التلاشي
وتعود الحياه طبيعيه نسبيا حركه في الشارع
قليلا للمواطنين وكذلك للعربات في منطقه
بحري لكن في ام درمان ما زال تسمع اصواتها
الرصاص والقنابل وكذلك
المدفعيات كذلك كل انواع المدافع بصوره
مكثفه جدا الان في اندرمان
بالنسبه لبقيه الاوضاع السياسيه التصعيد
هو شعار الموقف حتى هذه اللحظه لم يوجد
حتى الان موضوع للتهدئه كل المواضيع كل
الامور او التصريحات
توصل الى حقيقه واحده وهو ان الامر
سعيد قائد الجيش قال انه فوجئ بمهاجمه
قوات الدعم السريع لمنزله في التاسعه
صباحا كل المرافق الاستراتيجيه ذكرت هذه
القوات الجيش برهان ان كل المرافق
الاستراتيجيه من القياده والقصر تحت
السيطره وذكر الدعم السريع مسللت في
المطار عبر صاله الحجم العمره واحرف البعض
الطائرات وقواتنا هي التي تعاملت معها
بحسم
وشدد واكد على ان الاوضاع تحت السيطره
وانه لن يكون هناك اي تفاوض على الاطلاق
ولا حوار الا بعد حسم هؤلاء المتفلتين
في الجانب الاخر القائد قوات الدعم السريع
يتاسف على غسل ابناء شعبنا كما ذكر وقال
وضعنا جيد ونصيك على جميع المقام وقال
قواتنا اضطرت الى الدخول في المواجهه
الى الدخول الى هذه المواجهه
واشدد على انه اخبر الرباعيه ومجموعه
الوساطه بان هذا الرجل يقصد البرهان انه
كاذب وسيدمر السودان وذكر انه سيواصل
ملاحقه البرهان وسنسلمه الى العداله كل
هذه التصريحات يفهم منها ان التصعيد هو
سيد الموقف حتى اللحظه طيب سالم ساعود الى
الشقه السياسي ودت فقط ان استفسر عن بعض
التفاصيل الميدانيه نرى في الصور المباشره
التي تاتينا من الخرطوم على ما يبدو بانه
عاد التيار الكهربائي بعد ان كان هناك بعض
الانقطاع في بعض المناطق ما هي حقيقه هذا
الامر
حتى عوده التيار الكهربائي هي عوده جزئيه
لبعض المناطق لا تزال هناك مناطق كثيره
جدا
من بحري ومن الخرطوم ومنهم بيرمان هذا
الخيار الكهربائي منقطع من هذه المناطق
ولكن بعض المناطق عاد اليها السياره
الكهربائي لكن بقيه المناطق او المناطق
الاكثر هي التي لم يعد اليها الدائره
الكهربائي حتى هذه
ولم مشاكل في الانترنت على الاقل
هناك مشكله في الانترنت ايضا انه ثقيل
يعني نحن نواجه مشكله الان حتى في التواصل
معكم في القناه فيما يتعلق بالانترنت الى
اللجوء الى واي فاي وكذا او تشغيل لانه
الانترنت فيه مشكله لكن الاتصالات على ما
يرام طيب
يسيطر تسيطر عليها قوات الدعم السريع في
الخرطوم كان هناك حديث عن انها سيطرت على
مبنى
التلفزيون هل ما زالت هذه هي حقيقه الموقف
هناك او اي مناطق اخرى
وطبعا قبل ان تبدا بالحديث فقط مشاهدينا
نلفت انتباهكم الى اننا ما زلنا مع هذه
الصور الحيه من الخرطوم وقد سمعنا قبل
قليل تراشق بالرصاص على ما يبدو في اشاره
الى عوده الاشتباكات بين
الخرطوم على الاقل دعونا نستمع قبل ان
يكمل سالم
نعم اذا مشاهدينا كنا مع هذه الصور
المباشره التي ما زالت معنا من الخرطوم
نرى او كنا سمعنا قبل قليل اطلاق للرصاص
على ما يبدو الاشتباكات عادت في بعض
المناطق ايضا عوده التيار الكهربائي بشكل
جزئي لبعض المناطق في الخرطوم وبحري وام
درمان حسب ما افاد مراسلنا قبل قليل اعود
مره اخرى لسالم الهاشمي مراسلنا في
الخرطوم سالم تفضل كنت سالتك عن المناطق
التي او المرافق التي يسيطر عليها قوتك
نعم ذكرتي مبنى لدعوه تلفزيون هذا ما وردت
الينا من انباء ان تسيطر عليه بالكامل
قوات الدعم السريع الجيش حتى هذه اللحظه
بل انه في بيان نتحدث على ان هذا الامر
ليس في بيان وانما في حديث جيش بان
السيطره على المبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون
ايضا جزئيا وليس كاملا والدعم السريع اكدت
انها تسيطر
بالكامل حتى هذه اللحظات اكدت ايضا انها
سيطرت على مطار الدولي وسيطره عبره على
القاعده الجويه في جبل اولياء ومطار مروي
كذلك ومطار الخرطوم هذا ما اكدته الدعم
السريع جاء الجيش فنفع هذا الامر
بشكل كامل على مطار الخرطوم وان هذه
الانباء غير صحيحه وان الامور تحت السيطره
الجيش السوداني ايضا اكد انه لن يقف حتى
يلغي هذه التغلفات وصف هذه القوه لانها
قوه متمرده وانها عدو للسودان ويجب ان
يصطفها الجميع للدفاع عن السودان طيب قبل
قليل وردنا هذا النبا يتحدث عن تدمير قوه
للدعم السريع التي كانت متواجده في لواء
الرجيمان طبعا من قبل قوات الجيش السوداني
في ام درمان هل لديك اي معلومات عن هذا
الموضوع على ما يبدو انه هذه كانت
اشتباكات في محيط المهندسين سلاح
المهندسين على هذه الاشتباكات اشتباكات
سلاح المهندسين اشتدت بعنف بعد الافطار
ومكانت قبل الافطار هي اصلا مشتده وقويه
لكن زادت وسيرتها بشكل كبير جدا بعد ساعات
الافطار مباشره او بعد الافطار مباشره
وذكر الجيش السوداني بانه يسيطر على
السلاح المهندسين بالكامل وان هذه القوه
دمرت بالكامل كما ذكر الجيش ومصادر
الجيشيه اكدت هذا المعنى هذه الاشتباكات
في سلاح المهندسين لان سلاح المهندسين
واحد من الاسلحه المهمه جدا في الجيش
السوداني وفي منطقه حيويه جدا ايضا في ام
درمان فيه ما رافق عسكريه كبيره جدا محيطه
بسلاح المهندسين من كل الاتجاهات بما فيها
السلاح الطبي وغيرها من الاسلحه الموجوده
قريبه من سلاح المهندسين فهي منطقه عسكريه
حساسه جدا لذلك تعامل معها السوداني بهذه
الطريقه شكرا جزيلا لكم العربيه سالم
الهاشمي كان معنا من الخرطوم ونبقى هناك
ايضا مشاهدينا معنا محمد عصمت يحيى رئيس
الحزب الاتحادي الموحده اهلا بك استاذ
محمد معنا استاذ محمد كيف تقراون هذا
المشهد المتصاعد في السودان بشكل عام
هو مشهد
مؤسف
ومؤلم ان يعني يشتعل هذا الصراع بين
القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع
والبلد كانت تنتظر ان يتم
التوقيع على
السياسي النهائي
وبالتالي تبدا مرحله انتقاليه مدنيه تقود
البلاد الى انتخابات حره ونزيهه بعد عامين
من قيام هذه الحكومه
الصراع
القائمه الان بين القوات المسلحه والدعم
السريع صراع لا يخدم الا انصار النظام
البائد ولا يخدم الا الطامحين في
ثروات وموارد السودان
المهوله على ذكر فنون نظام استاذ محمد كان
هناك فرضيه بانه يعني فلول النظام البائد
او السابق هي من زرعت بذور الفتنه واجججت
هذا الوضع ما بين الطرفين هل يمكن ان تكون
هذه الفرضيه صحيحه
حقيقه هي ايام زرعت بذور الفدنه وظلت تعمل
على تاجيج نيرانا حتى اندلعت وهي الان
يعني تابعتي كل
الاسافير والميديا بتلغي كل الغرف
الاعلاميه الخاصه
والكتاب والنشطات
من النظام البائد
يطلبون مزيد من الزيت على هذا على هذا
الصراع الذي لم يبقي ولن يزل
اذا ما استمر ايام طويله او ابيض هذا
الصراع لا يستفيد منه السودان ولا شعب
السودان الذي كان يعمل ويطمح ان يرى خلال
الايام القليله القادمه
حكما مدنيا ديمقراطيا انتقاليا يقود
البلاد كما ذكرت
الى انتخابات
لذينه وحره نعم ولذلك نحن حقيقه في الحزب
الاتحادي الموحد يا استاذه نطالب حقيقه
اخواتنا في قيادات القوات المسلحه وقيادات
الدعم السريع بان يلتقوا الى مستوى الوطني
المطلوب في مثل هذه المراحل عليهم ان
يوقفوا هذه
الحرب فورا وان يعودوا الى مواقعهم التي
كانوا عليها قبل الفجر
حتى الان حتى الان يعني ما سمعناه من
المكون المدني من شتى الاحزاب والفصائل
السودانيه كلها طبعا شجب واستنكار ودعوات
لوقف هذا التصعيد العسكري فورا
ماذا يمكن ما هو الدور الذي يمكن ان يلعب
المكون المدني بشكل اكبر وفعال في انهاء
هذا المشهد الذي نراه الان
المكونه المدني حتى فجر اليوم كان في
اجتماع مع قائد الجيش السوداني الفريق اول
برهان وهو رئيس مجلس السياده
وتوصل هذا الاجتماع الى تكوين لجنه ثلاثيه
برئاسه دكتور الهادي ادريس عضو مجلس
القياده وعضويه كل من مدير
العمليات بالقوات المسلحه ومدير العمليات
في الدعم السريع للعمل على وضع حلول لهذه
الازمه وكان من المنتظر ان تعمل هذه
اللجنه منذ اليوم على على كيفيه معالجه
هذه الازمه حتى تتطور حتى لا تتطور الى
هذه الصراع
الدامي ولكن طبعا وجئنا كلنا كسودانيين
بانفجار الاوضاع مع فجر اليوم وما زالت
يعني الان
الاجواء
زي ما بقولوا تضيق بالدانات وبالرصاص
وبالقذائف ويمكن لو يعني انصت السمع الى
الى الى حديثي الان في منطقه ام درمان في
ضاحيه
الحتانه ما زال الصراع قائم وماذا
يعني صوت
الذخائر موجود يعني
مباشره على الهواء استاذ محمد ودت ان
اسالك عن هذا الخبر العاجل الذي او ردد
اوردناها ونراها الان على الشاشه مصادر
العربيه تقول قرار مرتقب للجيش السوداني
يحل فيه قوات الدعم السريع ويوقف الانتداب
اليها هل لديك اي معلومات عنه وماذا يعني
هذا القرار
لدي اي معلومات نحن طبعا نعاني من انقطاع
الكهرباء منذ الصباح
ونحتفظ نحتفظ بكهرباء قليله
للاتصالات لكن
يعني انا
ارى ان
التصعيد والتصعيد المضاف من كل من كل جانب
لن يزيد الازمه الا اشتعالا نحن في هذه
المرحله بنطلب يعني من القيادات الجيش
وقيادات الدعم السريع انهم يوقفوا هذا
الصراع فورا يعني ما في لا يوجد اي حل غير
ايقاف هذا هذا الصراع ولذلك يعني نخشى ما
نخشى ان اذا كانت تصريحات التي تخرج من
الطرفين متشابهه تتحدث عن انه نحن غير
مستعدين الحوار ولا حوار مع الطرف الاخر
حتى على ما يبدو حسم المعركه عسكريا على
الارض يعني في ظل هذا المشهد كيف سيكون
هناك هامش للوساطه وللحوار لوقف هذا تصعيد
العسكري
لو سمعت هذا يعني قبل قبل التهليل لكن انا
عايز اقول انه نحن كسودانيين عرفنا انه في
في احلك
الظروف وادق
المحكات عاده ما يجتمع السودانيين على
كلمه سواء نحن بنطلب وما زلنا نطلب ولن
نمل من الله من الطلب انه ان نحتفل جميعا
الى صوت العقل هذا صراع لو امتد سيمتد الى
كل اطراف البلاد وسيكون حرب شامله كويس
لانه نحن نعلم تماما ان القوات المسلحه
منتشره في كل انحاء البلاد ونعلم ان الدعم
السريع منتشر في كل انحاء
السودان ولذلك الحرب الان
خطورتها ليست فيما يجري داخل العاصمه
القوميه وانما نقشا ما نقشه ان تمتد وفعلا
تظهر امتدادات لهذه الحرب في
كالابيض
والجنينه
ونفسها مع نقشها ان يحدث ايضا في كسله وفي
الشرق وفي الشمال لذلك المطلوب ويظل هو
ايقاف هذه الحرب واللجوء الى صوت العقل
والاحتكام الى هذه الاطارات التي اجتهدت
منذ الصباح ومنذ الاجتهاد هذه الحرب
بواسطه قيادات سودانيه
ودول صديقه للسودان حتى يعني لا نذهب
بعيدا في هذا النفق المظلم طيب ابقى معي
يا استاذ محمد مشاهدينا نذكركم ببعض
الاخبار العاجله التي تاتينا الان قائد
اذن قوات الدعم السريع للعربيه يقول
سنواصل القتال ولم ننسحب من مواقعنا وايضا
مشاهدينا نعرض عليكم هذا الفيديو
هذا الفيديو
يظهر فيه قوات او تظهر فيه قوات الجيش
السوداني وتؤكد سيطرتها على مقر سلاح سلاح
المهندسين في ام درمان بعد ان كانت
الانباء تحدثت عن سيطره قوات الدعم السريع
اذا
فلنتابع
اربعه يوم السبت الموافق نحن الان في
طرفانه سلاح المهندسين او طرفانه منطقه
عسكريه سلاح المهندسين الناس اللي
بيتكلموا عن سلاح المهندسين فقط نحن الان
في قلب سلاح المهندسين وامام العرس
الرئيسي وامام علم السودان
[تصفيق]
اربعه يوم السبت الموافق نحن الان طيب اذا
نعود مشاهدينا لضيفنا محمد عصمت يحيى في
الخرطوم اهلا بك مره اخرى استاذ محمد
استاذ محمد اذا راينا قبل قليل هذا
الفيديو لا اعتقد لا اعرف اذا كنت على
الاقل استمعت اليه يقول لقوات الجيش
السوداني تؤكد سيطرتها على مقر سلاح
المهندسين في ام درمان كما كنا ذكرنا قبل
قليل في المقابل هناك ايضا تصريحات لرئيس
قوات الدعم السريع تتحدث عن انه يعني ما
زالوا يقاتلون ولم يتراجعوا عن مواقعهم
يعني يبدو ان هناك تصريحات متضاربه من
الطرفين ما هي حقيقه الامر ميدانيا اذا
كان لديك يعني معلومات
[موسيقى]
استاذ محمد
طيب يبدو اننا نعاني من بعض المشكله في
الاتصال او في الصوت سنحاول اعاده الاتصال
باستاذ محمد بعد قليل لكن معنا الان من
الخرطوم الصحفي والمحلل السياسي خالد الفك
اهلا بك استاذ خالد بدايه
قراءتك للمشهد بكل هذه التطورات المتسارعه
قوات الدعم السريع تسيطر على بعض المرافق
ومن ثم يتم نفي ذلك او استعاده الجيش
السوداني السيطره على هذه المرافق الى اين
تتجه الامور برايك
استاذ خالد
نعم نعم تفضل هل سمعتني
اعتقد بان الاوضاع
تسد نحو مزيد من الانفجار وسقوط عدد من
الضحايا في ظل تصريحات والتاكيدات من
القوات المسلحه بانها لن تدعم الامر الا
بعد ان تحسم تفل وتمرد الدعم السريع وكذلك
قبل قليل بان حمدان
انه مستمر في القتال ولن يتزحزح ولن ينسحب
من المواقع التي حازها فبالتالي يبدو الان
ان الصراع هو صراع كسري عظام وان الامر
معقد جدا في ظل في ظل التصريحات المضاده
في ظل التحشيش المضاد في ظل محاوله
السيطره على مواقع استراتيجيه في ظل
محاوله نقل
على ما يبدو على الاقل مما تتحدث الانباء
بانه معظم المرافق الحيويه تحت سيطره
الجيش
نعم نعم انا اشير الى ان الان
الصراع ينتقل الى مناطق غريبه من الاحياء
السكانيه فبالتالي لذا نسمع زكاه الرصاص
والدهانات
الشاشات بين الفئات الاخرى مما يشير الى
عمليات كر وفر في مناطق قريبه من الاحياء
وربما محاولات لقطع الامداد
لاقوى من قبل المسلحه لقوات الدعم السريع
اذا كان هناك اي قوه متمركزه خارج الخطوبه
تريد الدخول في مناطق غريبه فبالتالي
الاوضاع الان يعني صعب جدا
في الخرط
وم تحتفظ بحريه الان عباره عن سكنه عسكريه
اغلاق للجسور للطرق الرئيسيه
المدرعات والدبابات منتشره بكثافه في
مداخل
ومخال الان حتى قبل قليل يعني انا
ذهبت في جوله قريبه من من الشارع الرئيسي
في الحي وجدتها ان هناك الان اتفاق كبير
جدا
للسيارات امام
محطات الخدمه طلبا للوقود وهذا يجي ايضا
بدخول ومخاص من السكان والمواطنين بحدوثه
في المواد الاستهلاكيه الرئيسيه فبالتالي
اعتقد ان الصراع الان
سينتهي في وقت قريب في ظل زرار كله طرف
على كسر العظام اعترف الاخر ومحاوله تحقيق
مكاسب ربما في ظل ما نشفت الان ودعوات
للتفاوض يريد كل طرف ان يكون لديه اكبر
مكاتب حتى اذا اذا تم سماع صوت العقل رغم
انني
استطيع ان اقرا من التصريحات التي صدرت من
كافه القيادات العسكريه ومما شاهدناه بان
لا احد الان يرغب في في سماع صوت الحوار
او الجلوس وترك البندقيه الان الكل يتمسك
بالبندقيه ويتمسك باطلاق رصاص
او على الاخر وتحقيق مكاسب بالقوه وليس
بالحوار وهذا امر مؤسف ونقشه ان تتزايد
لاعداد القتلى واعداد الجرحى التي هي الان
تتصاعد بشكل كبير جدا في عدد من الولايات
خاصه من الدارفور قبل قليل كنت اتحدث
خبر عاجل الان وردنا فيما يتعلق بغربيه
دارفور تحديدا قائد قوات الدعم السريع
يقول انه تمت السيطره على مطار الجنينه
غربي الدارفور يعني على ما يبدو بانه
بالفعل يعني هي معركه من يسيطر على اي
مرفق حيوي قبل الاخر هذا هذا يعني اصبحت
عليه المعركه الميدانيه على ما يبدو حتى
الان
نعم نعم لذا انا كنت اتحدث قبل قليل ما حد
اصدقاء صحفيين في مياله غاليه الوضعي
مساوي وكارثي وللاسفه ان هناك عدد من
الجثث ملقى
على ملقى
على الاقلاع الطريق
والمنازل
وانفجارات والرصاص يعني بكثافه وهذا امر
خطير جدا الدعم الفريق يقول يعني سيطره
على مطاعملها مطار
الجنينه في والان هناك معارك تدور في في
وهناك تدور للسيطره على مدار الابيض في
شمال في شمال كردفان اذا هي محاوله لتحقيق
المكاتب من خلال السيطره على مواقع
الاستراتيجيه في عدد من الولايات الرئيسيه
والدخول ونقل هذه الحرب التي بدات في مروي
والخرطوم الى مناطق في دارفور ونخشيه ان
يمتد الصر
اع في
او في شركه سودان نعم استاذ خالد هناك خبر
عاجل ايضا الان نراه على الشاشه الجيش
السوداني يطلب من المدنيين عدم الاشتباك
مع قوات الدعم السريع فسر لنا هل اشتبكت
قوه
اشتبك المدنيون مع احد الطرفين في الساعات
الماضيه لانه الانباء كانت تتحدث عن
اصابات عدد كبير من المدنيين جراء يعني
بانهم علقوا في مهب اطلاق النار ما بين
والاشتباكات ما بين الطرفين
نعم نعم لان هذه هذه الاشتباكات للاسف
وقعت في لم يعني يكون متوقع وبدايتها كانت
عند التاسعه صباحا ودخول عدد كبير من
المواطنين الى وسط الخرطوم والى اعمالهم
والى والطلاب الى
الاحداث وهم في مدرسه بقرب الخرطوم
للبق
اء وهم في وضع
مشاوي هذه الاحداث تساعدت في وقت
ابقى معي دعونا نستمع مشاهدينا الى
الاصوات المباشره والحيه
اذا مشاهدينا كنا نستمع الى هذه الاصوات
للاشتباكات على ما يبدو التي تجددت في
الخرطوم في الدقائق الاخيره
ارجو ان يبقى معي استاذ خالد كنا نتحدث
معه قبل قليل اعود مره اخرى الى ضيفنا
محمد عصمت يحيى من الخرطوم استاذ محمد على
ما يبدو هل يمكن القول بانه هذه
الاشتباكات في الخرطوم على الاقل قد اشتدت
وارتفعت وتييرتها كما استمعنا
ليست الخرطوم فحسب انا يعني يمكن الان
هنالك اشتباكات في ام درمان وانا قريب من
يعني من منطقه هذه الاشتباكات ونسمع الان
الصوت صوت
الذخائر
بكثافه يعني
في هذه المنطقه ايضا يوجد معسكر كبير جدا
للدعم السريع وايضا هنالك مناطق عسكريه
تابعه للقوات المسلحه تمتد تقريبا من
كوبري الحلفايه وحتى القاعده الجويه وادي
سيدنا
والكليه الحربيه ويبدو انه
هذه الاصوات اصوات الدهانات
ما زال هنالك يعني
يعني
صراع بين الطرفين في هذه
المنطقه وهذا امر مؤسف وحقيقه انه يعني
طوال هذه الساعات ان يستمر هذا الصراع
يعني هذا الصراع الدامي
الذي يعني لا يوجد له ما يبرر في الدوله
تطمح يعني ان تكون
دوله مدنيه والدوله
مقبله على فتره انتقاليه
اكثر من 30 عام من الدمار والقراب حتى
تلحق ببقيه
الدول يعني ما يجري الان انا مازل انه
واهم من يعني من يستطيع ان يحسم هذا هذا
الصراع لانه حقيقه ان احنا كل صراعاتنا
وحروباتنا في السودان لم تحسم عسكريا
وانما
حسمت باتفاقات سياسيه
اذا كانت التصريحات من الجانبين اسمح لي
يعني قياده الجيش تقول نسمن جهود الوساطه
سواء كانت عربيه دوليه او حتى سودانيه
مدنيه ولكن لا حوار مع الطرف الاخر قوه
الدعم السريع تقول بالضبط نفس التصريحات
هل يمكن لاي وساطه سواء كانت دوليه او حتى
افريقيه او عربيه ان تكون المفتاح في حل
هذه الازمه
اصلا لا يوجد اي حل لهذه لهذه الازمه غير
الجلوس بين الطرفين والوصول الى حلول
يعني كل الخلافات التي كانت دائره خلال
المرحله الفاسده ما بين القوات المسلحه
وقوات الدعم السريع انا افتكر انها كلها
تم حلها ويمكن كان تبقى نقطه وحيده اللي
هي المساله المتعلقه بمركز او المركز
الموحد للقياده والسيطره وكان هنالك خلاف
يمكن ايضا ان يحل في يعني في تبعيه هذه
القياده المركزيه الموحده هل لقائد الجيش
الموحد والمدمج فيه الدعم السريع ام تكون
التبعيه لرئيس مجلس السياده المدني وكانت
هذه النقطه الوحيده المت بين الطرفين وكان
يمكن ان تحل وبالتالي يتم التو
قيع في النهائي
والتياسيه بقي
امه مدنيه انتقاليه
في هذه
المرحله اصلا لا يوجد خلاف ليس له حل يعني
كل الخلافات يمكن ان تحل يعني
طيب ابقى معي استاذ محمد مشاهدينا فقط
سنعرض عليكم بعض الان يعني بهذا الفيديو
لتصاعد الدخان من احد المباني في
الخرطوم قبل قليل
اذا مشاهدينا ما زلنا معكم في هذه
التغطيه الحيه والمباشره
لابرز طبعا الاحداث في الساعات الاخيره في
السودان
نعود مره اخرى الى ضيفنا في الخرطوم
الصحفي خالد الفكي
استاذ خالد هل ما زلت معنا
نعم نعم
استاذ خالد يعني واضح بانه الامور مرجحه
للتصاعد قبل قليل الاستاذ محمد كان يتحدث
ويقول بانه لا حل عسكري وكل معارك السودان
لم تحسم عسكريا ولكن من الواضح بانه يعني
الطرفان او طرفين
يحاولان
تحقيق مكاسب على الارض عسكريا قبل الوصول
الى مرحله الحوار التي
يرفضها في هذه المرحله
نعم نعم هذا هذا هو الواضح يعني اعتقد ان
الان الجميع او الطرفان وتحديدا لرغبات في
سماع صوت البندقيه فقط
ومحاوله الحوار بطريقه القوه وليس من خلال
السماح لطرف ثالث بالدروس معهم في في
الغرف المغلقه ونقل الرؤى وايجاد محاولات
لك يعني تقرب وجهات النظر الطرفان الان
كله طرف يحاول ان يستخدم كل ما لديه من
قوه
عظم الاخر وتحقيق مكاسب ميزانيه
ان تكون هي ورقه ضغطي في التفاوض في وقت
غريب ولكن يعني الان المخاوف من الدخول
الذي وظلمات الليلي ويعني في ظل
انتشار دائره
السماعه الاصوات الدهانات
والرشاشات وهذه مساحه يعني تخلق الجميع ان
اي طرف من الاطراف يحاول في جنح الليل
محاوله كسبي مواقع جديده محاوله مداهمه
ومل
احقه الطرف الثاني ومحاوله
دعنا نستمع الى على ما يبدو الاشتباكات
تتصاعد بشكل كبير
[تصفيق]
طب اذا مشاهدينا كنا نستمع الى هذه
الاصوات المتصاعده على ما يبدو
لتجدد الاشتباكات وكانها يعني الاصوات
تشير وكانها حرب شعواء بالفعل
ونرى ايضا على يمين الشاشه اندلاع النيران
السنه اللهب ترتفع وحتى يعني اصوات الرصاص
والقذائف تقترب بشكل كبير من موقع
الكاميرا كما تشاهدون
ساعود مره اخرى لضيفي من الخرطوم استاذ
خالد استاذ خالد هل لديك اي معلومات عن
هذه المناطق التي تتجدد فيها الاشتباكات
بهذا العنف
وتيره متصاعده جدا من العنف وكانها حرب
يعني بشكل جدي
ان ليله سيكون هكذا فكيف يكون مثير للسكان
والر
صاصهم
والتوقعات
بانفجارات لا لا يعني واخلاق لا تعرف اين
اين ستقع مرات وعلى من على
راس من اعتقد بان هذه المشاهد المزعجه
والمخيبه التي على طموح الان على شهادتكم
هي الان في وسط الخرطوم لانه فيما يبدو ان
المعركه لم تحسن تماما يبدو ان هناك ما
زالت
اخوه يعني تعمل سريع الجيش في محاوله
مواقع داخل
الخطوط على محيط المواقع الافتراضيه
الرئيسيه
يبدو ان هذه المعارك ستكون على شدها واننا
لخط يعني سيكون
صعب جدا على سكنه
مشاهدينا
اذا مشاهدينا ما زلنا مع هذه الصور الحيه
والمباشره واصوات لاطلاق نار كثيف اذا على
ما يبدو هذه الصوره التي نراها ونسمع
اطلاق النار قريب جدا من موقع الكاميرا هو
في محيط القياده العامه للجيش السوداني في
الخرطوم على ما يبدو هناك اشتباكات عنيفه
جدا في تلك المنطقه ايضا نرى السنه اللهب
كما ترونها في يمين الشاشه ترتفع ربما من
نفس المنطقه
لا ادري اذا اصبح مراسل مراسلنا سالم
جاهز معنا يبدو انه غير جاهز سنعود له
اصبح جاهز معنا سالم هل تسمعني
اولا نريد ان نطمئن عليك هل انت في نفس
الموقع موقع الكاميرا التي نراها لانه على
ما يبدو النيران واطلاق النار قريب جدا من
هذه المنطقه
نعم لست قريب من مكان الكاميرا لكن ما
يحدث هو اشتباك عنيف الان في قلب العاصمه
الخرطوم
هذه الاشتباسات وهذا
الاشتراك
في منطقه بالقرب من سلاح المهندسين ما
زالت ايضا الناريه وايضا في منطقه
الكليه الحربيه في شمال ام درمان بالقرب
من المدرعات في منطقه الجرافه ايضا هناك
ذوي اطلاق نار ايضا هناك ايضا بالقرب من
كبري الحقايه ايضا هناك ايضا لطلقات واعره
ناريه
واستخدام لمدافع هذه المناطق كلها ملتهبه
الان بشكل ملحد ومخيف جدا هذه هذا هذا
التصاعد بدا من بعد الافطار وزادت وسيرته
حتى هذه اللحظه نعم طب في محيط قياده
الجيش على ما يبدو وهي الصوره التي نراها
الان ما الذي يجري هل تحاول قوات الدعم
السريع يعني
السيطره على جزء منه او الهجوم عليه ما
الذي يجري هناك
نعم الان هي قوات الدعم السريع تحاول
السيطره على المنطقه المحيطه بالقياده
العامه للجيش والوصول اليها وكان الجيش
السوداني قد
ضرب المبنى الخاص بالقوات الدعم السريع
وتم هذا المبنى ان لم يكن بشكل كامل فشكل
كبير منه تم حرق هذا المبنى وضرب هذا
المبنى بشكل كبير ربما تاتي هذه هذا
التصعيد في مفهوم في هذا الاطار في اطار
انه ربما رد على ما حدث على المبنى مبنى
قوات الدعم السريع وهجوم شرس جدا
ويعني نسمع اصوات الاعرابيه بكثافه حتى
نحن هنا على بعد مسافه كبيره جدا مجتمع
الى هذه الاصوات منذ لحظات
والقنابل وغيرها من المداخل
[موسيقى]
طيب سالم
وده اسالك عن المواقع التي تشهد اشتباكات
الان فقط للتوضيح في
عفوا في الخرطوم تحديدا
نعم المناطق التي تتجدد فيها الاشتباكات
هي في ام درمان الخرطوم اكثرها بحري الى
حد ما فيها هدوء نسبيه في هذه اللحظات من
بعد الافطار وحتى هذه اللحظه الهدوء بدا
يعود الى حد ما الحركات تبدو شبه طبيعيه
وليست طبيعيه بالكامل هناك حلول الشوارع
حركه لكن خفت الاعين واستخدام القنابل
وكذلك اطلاق الرصاصه لكن في ام درمان
تجددت الاشتباكات في المهندسين وتجددت
الاشتباك في الشمال الكليه الحربيه وايضا
بالقرب من السكه الحربي اي قرب كوبري
الحلفايه هذه كلها المناطق الشمال في
القران كذلك وفي قلب العاصمه المحيط
القياده العامه
دعونا نستمع مشاهدي قوه
الجيش
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا ما زلنا معكم اذا في هذه الصور
الحيه والمباشره نستمع واياكم الى
اشتباكات عنيفه في محيط قياده الجيش
السوداني على ما يبدو وكما افاد مراسلنا
بان قوه الدعم السريع تحاول السيطره على
محيط قياده الجيش ارحب بضيفي من الخرطوم
ايضا الكاتب الصحفي شوقي عبد العظيم اهلا
بك استاذ شوقي معنا شوقي كيف تعلقون على
انفجار الوضع الان ويعني قياده الجيش على
ما يبدو هي مسرح لمعركه حاميه الوطيس ما
بين الطرفين
نعم
ان كل طرف كان يعتقد يعني انه يعني الحرب
في وقت
يسيطر على الاوضاع ولكن هذا لم يتحقق لاي
من الطرفين حتى هذه اللحظه ولذلك يبدو
المشهد ان هذه الحرب ربما ستطور
يتوقع القاده الذين قالوا انها فقط ساعات
وبعضهم ما قال يوم او يومين
حتى الان لا تدين لاحد
اعتبرها نحن نتجه الحرب المدن وحرب
الشوارع الكبير هل تتخوفون بانه قد يعني
تؤول الامور الى حرب اهليه داخل يعني
السودان
نعم يمكن التوصيفه حتى الان بحرب اهليه
لانها لشيء هي جيوش منظمه لبيع القوانين
تعمل كانت جيش
اوروبيش واحد وهو جيش لديه قانون السريع
ولكن
القياده ولديها وهكذا لا يمكن توصيفها
بحرب اهليه وانما هي حرب الجيش وجيش اخر
كان من المفترض ان يكون جيش
رياضي او جيش
توصيفات
شوقي يعني بعد بعد هذه المشاهد التي نراها
وبعد اليوم وهذا الشرخ ما بين هاتين
المؤسستين العسكريتين كيف سيتم راب هذا
الصدع
لاندماج قوات الدعم السريع ان شاء الله
بعد توصل الى اتفاق وانتهاء هذه المشاهد
العنيفه ولكن بعد هذا الصدع وبعد هذا
اليوم كيف يمكن دمج القوتين مع بعضهما
البعض في جيش واحد
هنالك هدنه او سلام بين الجانبين ولكن من
الواضح ان معطيات هذه المعرفه
تتقبل بشيء
الان وفي المستقبل القريب والبعيد هذه
المواجهه لم تكن متوقعه ولم تكن مقدره ظلت
الجيش يهدد وكذلك الدعم السريع لانهم لن
يتواجهوا ولن يرفع السلاح في وجه بعضهم
البعض الان هذا حدث هذا يعني انه سيؤشر
على هذه العلاقه الكبير
يؤثر على الدمج وشكل الجيش السوداني كله
في المستقبل تاثر بهذه المعرفه التي وقعت
اليوم طيب استاذ شوقي بدات حديثك بالقول
بانه على ما يبدو هي معركه معركه للسيطره
على المرافق
يعني من قبل احد الطرفين ولم يتسنى هذا
الامر حتى الان لاي منهما
هل نفهم من حديثك بانه يعني تقريبا هي
قوات متكافئه التي تتحارب وبالتالي لذلك
ستطول هذه المعركه
نعم بشكل كبير حتى الان تبدو الامور
المتكافئه والحسم لم يتم بشكل كبير سريع
ويتوقع احد ان تدور المعارك حتى في داخل
القياده العامه
او كما يجري في هذه اللحظات لذلك هي القوه
حتى الان لا تدير لاحد رغم
في خرطوم لديه معطيات اكبر من الدعم
السريع كما ذكرت لك في السابق جيش اليه
الان بيئه القتال هنا وربما مساعده للجيش
السوداني
وجود المدرعات وبوجود السلاح المدرعات
ربما الطيران ربما فعاليته تقل بشكل كبير
حرب المدن في هذه اللحظات ولكن لم تسيطر
جهه ونسمع الان في الانباء ثم يسي
طر الدعم ويصرح بانه
هو الذي على المكان طيب اسمح لي استاذ
شوقي في الاخبار العاجله التي وردت الان
المخابرات السودانيه تقول البرهان اصدر
قرار بحل قوات الدعم السريع كيف تعلقون
على قرار البرهان هذا وماذا يعني في اطار
ما نشهده الان في السودان
اني انفتحت على قوات الدعم السريع اليس
فقط على القياده او صراع مع القياده وانما
صراع مع فكره الدعم السريع هو متمرده يجب
ان يصيب
بهذا التوصيل فهذا اعلان حرب على جميع
المناطق لانه
الجيش لا تنساه للتعليمات فهي قوه متمرده
في هذا التوصيف يجب ان تنصاع ويجب ان
تسيطر عليها القوات المسلحه في اي مكان من
الامكنه
لا يعقد هذا القرار اي جهود وساطه يمكن ان
تنجح في انشاء انهاء هذا المشهد
في الوقت الحالي لا تجنح الجيوش الجيوش
الجيوش للوسطاء في هذه في هذه اللحظات من
المعركه من عمر الم
عرفه الجنود المعنويه بعدم الانكسار
والقبول بالصلح ربما تكون هنالك تفهمات
تفاهمات
سريه او تبدا منخفضه الصوت ولكن لا تعلم
في هذه اللحظات حتى لا تتاثر مع الجنود في
الساعات الاولى من المعرفه تعتبر هزيمه او
تعتبر تراجع او تعتبر عدم تكافؤ في القوى
لذلك لا احد يتوقع ان تقبل ان يقبل قياده
الجيش او قياده الدعم السريع اي وساطه او
القبول باي الجلوس باي من الاطراف ولكن
تبدا كما ذكرت لك بصوت منخفض بطريقه سريه
ببساطه غير
اللقاحات غير مباشره ثم ربما في الايام
المقبله
[موسيقى]
هذه من هي الاطراف يعني المرشحه
لقياده جهود وساطه اكثر نجاحا في اطار هذه
الازمه ربما بعد ايام او ربما بدات بالفعل
هذه الجهود نعم اعتقد المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والامارات
لقياده هذه الوساطه
المتحده الامريكيه نقول مجموعه الاربعه
الاليه الرباعيه في السودان اللي هي
الامارات والسعوديه وبريطانيا والمملكه
المتحده او الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هو
الرباعيه ثم ترويكا
كبير في هذه الوساطه طبعا معروف العلاقه
بين السعوديه
والجيش هي علاقه ممتده منذ حرب اليمن
افضل من ذلك فلذلك لديهم تاثير كبير على
على الجيوش الموجوده الان المتصارعه حاربه
في هذه المعرفه يمكن ان يقوده وفاقك جيده
واعتقد انها بدات منذ الساعات الاولى من
هذه الحرب نعم طيب فقط مشاهدينا نذكركم
ببعض الاخبار العاجله اذا اعلام السودانيه
يتحدث عن ارتفاع عدد قتلى الاشتباكات بين
الجيش والدعم السريع في الفاشر ونيالا الى
تسعه قتله ايضا مراسله العربيه كانت تحدث
وقال بان قوات الدعم السريه تحاول السيطره
على محيط قياده الجيش وهذا هذه هي المشاهد
التي نراها الان ونسمع اصوات هذه
الاشتباكات على ما يبدو في محيط قياده
الجيش السوداني ايضا المخابرات السودانيه
قالت بانه البرهان اصدر قرارا بحل قوات
الدعم السريع
ما زلنا مشاهدينا معكم في هذه التغطيه
المفتوحه لاحداث السودان ما زلنا مع هذه
الصور الحيه من الخرطوم من محيط قياده
الجيش السوداني مع تجدد الاشتباكات
العنيفه في تلك المنطقه حيث انا قوات
الدعم السريع تحاول السيطره على محيط
قياده الجيش
ايضا مشاهدينا مصادر في الجيش السوداني
ردا على المخابرات
قرار حل قوات الدعم الصراع السريع لم يصدر
حتى الان اذا هذا نفي من مصادر في الجيش
السوداني
للانباء التي وردتها المخابرات السودانيه
بان البرهان اصدر قرار بحلق قوات الدعم
السريع وقالت بان هذا القرار لم يصدر بعد
اذا مشاهدينا هذه التغطيه مستمره معكم
ننتقل الان مباشره الى الزميله ميسون
وايهد واعود لكم على راس الساعه القادمه
باذن الله